hey leute was geht electric setzt ihren
spaß ich bin hier und so und das erste
mal mit face cam am start weil mir
einige leute die sprache geschrieben
haben das heißt einige zu ca 10
milliarden wenn nicht sogar billionen
ganz klein bisschen übertrieben weil das
jetzt gebe ich dazu geht los geht los so
wir sind hier übrigens auf die heimfans
zweifel games und wir sind wieder auf
die akten mit auf der ich mich zornig
war woods evonik allerdings sich
aufgenommen wurde
diesmal ist das problem mein hund das
wird wieder nicht mit aufgenommen ist
einfach weil ich diese kopfhörer hat man
das erste mal benutzt hat meine iphone 5
kopfhörer
ganz einfach weil ich jetzt nicht mit
einem headset hier sitzen wollte
natürlich so das ist so klumpp ich
wissen dann seht ihr mich nicht dann
gehen wir diesen erfolg ab aber naja
erwartet dass die kisten mussten gleich
irgendwie darauf kommen ja ich kann mich
auch nicht umbenennen insoweit wir games
das auch relativ dürftig haben jetzt
allerdings gedacht dass ich jetzt mal
mit facetime aufnehme weil mir
einerseits ist ganz von den kommentare
geschimpft haben und andererseits habe
ich gerade drei stunden das heißt ich
wollte hier noch ein video drehen weil
ich heute noch kein video habe was ich
hochladen kann
ja ich weiß wie heiße ja hab ich mir
gedacht es geht um fünf sekunden
oh mein gott ich habe auf jeden fall
schon mal sachen das ja schon mal ganz
gut weil es geht hier natürlich sofort
los das ist natürlich so will games da
geht sofort los so ich will diesen
google twin server typen töten
ganz einfach weil er einen stein schwert
hat so ich bin auf jeden fall grad schon
mal ganz gut dabei schön aber liegen die
kamera
ich bin ging ich hoffe er ist keiner da
oben ist noch jemand der ist einfach auf
das ist auch schon mal ganz gut weil für
jeden kill kriegt man natürlich punkte
obwohl wenn der arzt kann man ihn
geschlagen ihr werdet nicht losgelaufen
ist kann man hier noch nicht war für
jeden kill kriegt man natürlich punkte
und das war natürlich eine ganz super
sache nahe freunde so was wie canopen
crazy geburt als solche sondern angeln
und das ist ja ja und so ein cooler
fresse weshalb wenn man so einen wurm
oder fresse wie sorgen sie das aloha
gucke mir gerne zu wie ich mich jetzt
mal aufmachen
gut ich hab mir gedacht ich mach einfach
meinen fans kam
ich wollte schon viel früher also als
ich gezeigt habe dass ich mir da kommt
nichts direkt mit festem auch was ist
meine canon kamera der 600d oder was ist
sich er also ich weiß nicht was mit ihr
kann man habe dann jedoch weiß ich wie
es kommt meinte einfach mal so zu sagen
ja du bewegst dich nicht das stop ich
doch einfach mal die aufnahme mitten
drin und ich natürlich so klug und ich
klappe immer den bildschirm der hier
neben habe hier den clip ich immer so
zurück damit ich ihn nicht nebenbei in
diesem bildschirm reinke und das mache
ich kann auch wieder das ist einfach so
dass man sich selbst anguckt weil
einfach so eine linse gucken was ich
jetzt gerade zum beispiel macht das
relativ schwierig für die menschen das
ist bei euch auch so wenn ich irgendwie
facetime macht oder so ich weiß nicht ob
ihr das macht also ich mach's nicht aber
wenn jetzt geld oder sogar ihr zeigt
euch und dagegen aber zum beispiel nicht
weil dann guckt ihr grundsätzlich euch
selber an und nicht halt irgendwo anders
hin oder in der kamera oder
in eure in euren webcam sondern hey ich
würde ich trotzdem
das ist so weil wir games da ist nichts
mit frieden alter der hat dabei ganz
schön der typ war gut
da kann ich nicht von oben sehen wie die
tweet da komm ich nicht 100 obwohl es
irgendwo eine kiste
das ist so eine kiste oder nähe ist
nicht ach so ich kann mir wer kennt es
nicht man kann sich mit minecraft so
weil da guck dir automatisch immer dann
neben rein in dem bildschirm wo ihr euch
weht und nicht in die linse ich sage
jetzt einfach mal dass das festgestellt
wurde von ihnen ganz professionell
wissenschaftlern keine ahnung aber jetzt
halt einfach so dass es menschliches
verhalten wenn die pädagogik hab dann
wisst ihr was das bedeutet ich habe
selbst kein paar da google hätte aber
gern mal gut ich habe gerade auch schon
wieder eine runde aufgenommen
auf die hable meinte sache ist
allerdings dass mein freebsd alter alter
alter lasst mich bitte in ruhe mein
fraps dabei ist abgestürzt und nicht
konnte die komplette aufgabe allerdings
nicht verwerten
wo es häufig aber gegen seine band gehen
ja das ist natürlich jetzt total optimal
blödmann nein nur noch zwei dinge weg
hoch verdammt
ich habe überhaupt keinen bock dass der
mich jetzt irgendwie fit mach ich
wirklich dieses ist er schneller als ich
weiß dass er gut mehr spiele gern machen
wir noch mal eine runde schnell wird bei
fünf minuten später ohne mal wenn sie ja
sonst nichts im leben da was das jetzt
so gibt es fünfmal so viele games 2 naja
kommende weg bin ein mensch ich koche
auch mit ganz normalem wasser ich
verstehe auch nicht warum werde ich
jetzt als star angesehen ist ich mag das
überhaupt nicht dass die leute mir dann
kontrollkräfte team von crafter ray
cooney kong kräfte special das ist zwar
cool dass ihr das so man jetzt auf mein
gott das kann mir also die sache die ich
nicht mag wenn er dann so leute an kommt
einfach überhaupt nicht schreiben können
wenn sie einfach nur rum nerven zum
beispiel graz und ihm kraft mich an das
kopiert oder das haus einfach abgespielt
ja ich kann dir beim vitabit selber
helfen das ist sehr schön ich habe
allerdings wenn ihr mir bei twitter
folgen würdet wirst du dir dass wir das
schon lang in gang gekriegt haben und
heute abend aufnehmen also auch da nicht
so aktuell kompakt hat ihn einlud marco
h so kann man ja schön ist das ja schon
das nächste hätte kann ich hier laufen
noch so ja ja okay das ist natürlich
dann ja ok starts in einer halben minute
also noch mal ganz kurz ich gucke
einfach grundsätzlich ich versuche immer
in die linse zu gucken dann muss ich
allerdings den bildschirm wegklappen
denke jetzt wahrscheinlich glauben doch
die bildschirm weg dann einfach ist dann
allerdings wieder die sache dass ich da
nicht sicher ob ich es wirklich
aufnehmen oder ob er mir gesagt hey du
bewegst dich zu wenig du kannst nicht
weiter aufnehmen
fabio
ich weiß jetzt gar nicht habe ich das in
dieser aufnahme gesagt dass mit fabio
dass ich gleich wieder zur schule fahre
oder nicht ja ich habe jedenfalls
freistunde und vergleich wieder zur
schule so und dann hätte ich mir nie
gespielt das ist aber nicht das was
zuvor abgestimmt habe na gut diese
person hat einen spieltag
das finde ich auch ganz schlimmer das
hat das ist auch so noch so eine person
mit fit aber ich verstehe das einfach
nicht warum macht man sich ins
bietigheimer es was bringt das
troll dann ist man schneller aber kann
einfach doppelt rücken
und ich verstehe ja gemein nicht warum
ein hektar oder chattet weil was machten
dann noch spaß
ich meine bei gta als das was anderes
dann mache ich das ja auch bei gta
spiele ich nie die story dort schied ich
einfach nur rum jetzt noch gott danke
für die kiste namen 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
oh mein gott ich sprinte ja nicht mehr
natürlich habe ich ihnen nur so karg
schuhe
und ich werde gleich wieder von ihnen
geschlagen na gut ich war erstmal so als
ob mich schwer bewaffnet wäre und
schlagt ihr auch alle dauer von bam und
prominenten schwert
da läuft mir doch nicht hinterher muss
hier irgendwie weg und überleben
da sind schon wieder so viele leute das
ist einfach so der sinn des lebens
einfach weglaufen und überleben leben
und leben lassen leute da und es nicht
tatsächlich noch eine kiste
doch das bringt jetzt alter was will der
denn die noch weg was soll da ist wieso
verfolgt er mich jetzt mit wünschen
hinterher gelaufen das ist so weil games
spielt man gegeneinander armen städten
helm auf skills lab pro mann lass mich
rein
[Musik]
lea alter wenn der typ ist nicht weggeht
dann schlage ich ihn aber mit der hand
tod wie wii fit wie doof bitte
[Musik]
walter nebel hatten helme lass das
träumen nicht wert noch hellmich haben
schuhe
mein gott das sind ja schon hier kämpfen
ganz ganz tiefen niveau der helm
ich habe schuhe noch hinter mir ich
nicht gucken aber das nimmt noch auf
mich nehmen darauf ja okay gibt es ja
schon mal ein positives zeichen
warum sind so viele hier im dorf noch
stärker hat gar nicht warum das hier so
kehlmann tc ist doch klar
und mein gott kommt dies länger
verstecken verstecken das ist mein gott
der hat eine angel war gahan gemacht
aber keinen schaden witzbold jeder kann
mich wegschubsen das ist ja toll gemacht
doch keinen schaden oder leute macht
eine angel schaden könnte das erst mal
genüsslich was essen hier
[Musik]
ich wünsche euch wieder gepflegt das ist
wie der saison ja komm her kommen auch
ich weiter schön und das ist mir nicht
cool
sorry übrigens dass sie kein tor falls
ich schon gesagt habe leider nicht jetzt
muss ich weglaufen
das ist ganz einfach aus dem grund weil
h angetäuscht ein okay ich schaffe das
nicht mehr weil ich ja gerade meine
kleinen kopfhörer von meinem iphone 5
und dementsprechend kein nord kann ich
nicht mehr sprinten
dementsprechend habe ich keine treiber
bisher dafür installiert bzw
allgemein nicht ob das überhaupt so
alles geht wie ich mir das keiner
ausgemalt habe dass ich die hier einfach
drin habe weil ich hörte hat selber
keinen sound deswegen habt ihr
wahrscheinlich hat auch kein ton
ja wieso lebe ich eigentlich noch ich
habe ein halbes herz also der auf mich
drauf geht es da bin ich direkt tot
egal mit was der mich schlägt und wie
für rüstung andere hatte ich kann jetzt
eigentlich nur weglaufen
also ja ich werde in zukunft auch
versuchen dass die kamera von hier wo
sie jetzt steht dahin stelle damit ja so
frontal drauf gucke sieht man ja leute
ich glaube ich bin jetzt einfach vom
berg runter das noch langweiliger wir
wollen keine runde vor mir sehen wo ich
einfach nur davonlaufen
darum ist ein typ ging es am gipfel
gefühl ein drache
ein drache von ihm möchte einen
screenshot machen und das auch schön da
unten das dorf das eigentlich auch voll
cool die maps an sich irgendwie relativ
cool ich laufe einfach mal so ein
bisschen rum und touristen
[Musik]
das sollten die risiken wasser verstärkt
sich noch nicht gesehen einfach schnell
ja leute also ich würde nicht sagen dass
ich jetzt mal runter springen ich weiß
dass man sowas geht daher die kamera
hält zwischendurch einfach mal so auf zu
filmen kein plan warum was ich weiß
nicht ob es mitbekommen habt aber ich
lasse jetzt einfach mal die sache hier
fallen und springer gleich einfach mal
einfach runter weil ich keinen bock hat
dass er einfach seine runde form ihr
seht kommen hier die schmidt ja dahin
das sind die schuhe die geschützt mich
bestimmt vom falschen
typischer spruch ich bin tot
ich würde sagen es euch gefallen hat
daumen hoch geben wenn es euch nicht
gefallen hat einfach auch norm hoch
hinein spaß freiheit freie
meinungsäußerung und soja heike christ
ich würde einfach sagen wenn es euch
gefallen hat ja dann dann schreibt auch
eine kommunale parteien gefallen hat
können auch in die kommentare schreiben
was eventuell noch so sehen wollt an
projekten und ob irgendwelche
verbesserung habt bezüglich facebook
habe ich das irgendwie besser darstellen
könnte tschüss und schöne ferien euch
übrigens sind auch noch ein paar
projekte geplant vor allem mit gomez was
geplant
daniela ist mit stephen auf jeden fall
eine menge damenklasse klasse idee super
ideen haben wir das ist richtig schocken
und erst mal gucken was daraus wird